Books inspire us.
They teach us.
They let us escape into new worlds.
But some books
do much more than this.
These books hit a collective nerve,
and have had a profound
and lasting effect on society.
What are the titles
that had this impact?
There are many, many books
that fit this definition,
but we've managed to narrow
it down to five books
that have truly shaped our world.
...wrote Robert Burton in his
enormous 900 page book,
The Anatomy of Melancholy.
Which was first published
way back in 1621.
So in the 17th Century,
there weren't books
about melancholy,
or as we would call it today,
depression.
It looks as if Robert Burton
himself suffered from depression.
And there's a real sense
as he writes it, that he's writing himself into a position
of expertise about depression, so he can help himself
as well as other people.
And it's remained such a
kind of influential book
over the centuries since then.
Not simply because
of its subject matter,
it's the way it's written -
it explores inner life
in a way that hadn't really
been explored before.
So it's the patient's voice.
And one of the things that we've
learnt over the last 20 years
is the importance
of the patient's voice,
in targeting research
and clinical treatment.
To 1960s America now,
where many people still thought
that a woman's place was in the home.
Betty Friedan wrote
The Feminine Mystique in 1963,
and in the introduction
describes it as,
"The problem that has no name."
It was a book writing about
the experience and aspirations
of women in suburban America.
It stood out as a book at this time
because the experience of women
wasn't being written about in
this way for the general population.
It stood out because she was
standing up and saying,
"We need to acknowledge that
there is more to life for these women
than being the perfect wife,
the perfect mother."
She developed the idea that women
needed to become politicised,
they needed to think about their
experience at home.
However,
and there is a big however,
the biggest criticism came from her
exclusion of women of colour.
Poor women's experience was excluded,
she also excluded lesbians.
Despite these shortcomings,
this book had real impact
at the time.
It bought feminism to a very wide
audience and that's a huge positive.
Bill McKibben's 1989 book,
The End of Nature,
is considered to be the first book
to bring global warming
to a general audience.
The End of Nature is about how humans
are changing the planet.
It's a sad lament
on human destruction.
In the 1980s, people had been
talking about global warming,
but it hadn't entered the public
consciousness as something
that we should be
really concerned about,
and we should be already acting on.
What he did with this book is really
wake people up
to this dramatic change that we are
having globally on the natural world.
And which now is taken for granted
by everybody,
we all are very aware
of the impact we're having.
And it's largely due to books
like this.
Things Fall Apart by Nigerian
author Chinua Achebe,
was one of the first
African novels in English
to gain global recognition
and acclaim,
and it is still read and studied
all over the world to this day.
Africa was always seen through
the eyes of the white colonials.
It was like a door opening
into a world
that white Europeans never understood
and even as it was published
people were astonished
by the beauty of the book.
Here comes a man who's talking about
Igbo villages in Nigeria
and their lives
and their inner thoughts
and their hopes and desires
and we'd never seen that.
And for Africans -
and that's the more important point -
there were emerging writers,
they knew their time was now,
they knew that the world was ready
and it was that book
that convinced them that it was.
And finally, to post-war Britain,
a time when many items
were still rationed,
and to Elizabeth David's
A Book of Mediterranean Food.
Britain already had
a reputation for poor food,
plain food, grey food.
She wrote it as a memoir almost,
of her time spent in southern Europe
before and during World War Two.
She wrote it really as a yearning
for these wonderful places
and the colours and the scents
and the flavours.
These days we completely take for
granted ingredients like chickpeas,
lemon, garlic,
olive oil, tomatoes, basil.
But then,
when this book was published,
none of those ingredients
were really available.
I mean, if you wanted
to buy olive oil,
you had to go
to a chemist's shop
because it was sold
for treating earache.
She triggered a movement
which we still feel today
which is one where food
becomes something important
not just to our daily routine
of nourishing ourselves
but saying a little bit more
about who we are.
So there's now multiple generations
of food writers
and cookery presenters
whose existence now would not have
been possible without that book.
Words on a page can do
so much more than entertain.
Some books have imagined,
explored and introduced ideas
which have had a lasting impact
on our society
which we experience to this day,
even if we haven't read them.